I was there almost every week for the
entire first season at about three books
a week I probably read over 50 books
that summer just sitting around with
nothing to do but stare off into space
and it just makes it a lot more livable
to have something to do as a leisure
time activity
there are a lot of misconceptions about
people who are living outside and one of
them is that they don't read or that
they wouldn't be interested in
literature or that they haven't been to
college
there are many assumptions people make
because we don't know their story part
of the street books mission is to offer
community and to restore the dignity of
people who have been kind of cast aside
or put at the margins of things
I think that patrons are often grateful
for the opportunity to fill up an
afternoon in a different world to be
transported from their current reality
if that's something that they are
struggling with
step right up folks get the books get
the stories we got short stories long
stories - stories love stories war
stories and morning glories